berlinlichtenberg dieses leerstehende
Seniorenheim wird zur Unterkunft für
Asylsuchende Ende Oktober sollen die
neuen Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner
einziehen bevor es losgeht ist die
Nachbarschaft eingeladen kommunikation
ist alles in diesen Tagen das weiß auch
der Bezirksbürgermeister ich sag's frei
heraus ich glaube kein Bezirk schreit
hurra wenn es heißt neue Unterkünfte
aufzumachen wir müssen Strukturen
schaffen wir müssen die Nachbarschaft
mitnehmen wir müssen über ehrenamtliche
wir müssen über Schule und
das S so wesentliche Faktoren es dann
auch zum Gelingen bringen knapp über 100
Menschen sollen hier einziehen mehr
Bettzimmer mit Bart auch für
Pflegebedürftige geeignet das Haus ein
Glücksfall für die zuständige Behörde
doch viele in der Nachbarschaft sind
skeptisch schon jetzt ist Lichtenberg
einer der Berliner Bezirke der besonders
viele geflüchtete unterbringt wir haben
hier hinten noch eine weitere
Einrichtung in der sich Flüchtlinge
befinden aus
Afghanistan wir haben die nchste 300 m
weg ukrainische Flüchtlinge und wir
haben die vierte Einrichtung ungefähr 1
km weg meiner Meinung nach besteht kein
kein Problem mit geflüchteten und 108
erscheint mir bei der Größe von
Lichtenberg sowieso eine marginale Zahl
es kann nicht sein dass vier Berliner
Bezirke die Hauptlast der
flüchtlingsunterkünft tragen und ich
habe große Angst dass unter Engagement
was heute noch da ist und was auch in
der Bevölkerung no da ist dass das durch
diese Blindheit kippt der Bezirk fordert
mehr Geld und eine gerechtere Verteilung
in Berlin und auch die Anwohner haben
viele Fragen wer kommt wer kümmert sich
wann dürfen die Menschen arbeiten das
Thema Migration ist ein gravierendes
oder polarisiert und da fühlten
offensichtlich viele Leute alleinelassen
und dass diese Leute hier auch
tatsächlich betreut werden und dass
diese Integration oder zumindest
Betreuung erfolgt gerade ringt Berlin
schl um mehr Schlafplätze die größte
Unterkunft ist auf dem ehemaligen
Flughafen Tegel stad Start und Landebahn
Leichtbauhallen mit Betten für rund 4000
geflüchtete schon jetzt ist es eine
Kleinstadt und die wächst im Eiltempo
werden die nächsten Hallen aufgebaut für
dann auf engstem Raum insgesamt 7000
Menschen wir arbeiten hier im Bereich
der Abwendung von Obdachlosigkeit das
ist uns hier allen klar wir machen uns
nichts vor wir wissen dass wir eine Art
der Unterbringung bieten die eine
absolute
und daher ist die Not natürlich groß
wenn man sowas macht und nicht eine
Unterbringung wie es eigentlich sein
muss was auch unser Ziel ist diezentral
in kleineren Einrichtungen mit
Privatsphäre doch ohne die
massenunterkünfte geht es nicht neben
den geflüchteten aus der Ukraine nahm
Berlin bis September allein 12000
Asylbewerber auf rund ein Drittel mehr
als im Jahr zuvor Tegel sollte mal ein
Übergang für Tage oder wenige Wochen
sein doch die Menschen bleiben
monatelang zu 15 in einem Raum und doch
ist diese Afghanis Familie
dankbar niemand kann uns hier einfach
erschießen deswegen sind wir gekommen
wegen unserer Kinder auch in der Markus
Kirchengemeinde in Berlin Steglitz haben
Menschen Zuflucht gefunden seit Ausbruch
des ukrainekrieges ist der Gemeindesaal
zur Notunterkunft geworden mehrere
geflüchtete teilen sich einen der
abgetrennten Räume Olga kachanova und
ihre Familie waren erst bei Verwandten
untergebracht doch dort wurde es auf
Dauer zu eng seit se Monaten sind sie
hier wir hätten gerne eine eigene
Wohnung aber hier ist es ruhig und wir
haben alles die geht hier in die Schule
und die Umgebung gefällt uns und wir
haben nette
Nachbarn nette Nachbarn ehrenamtliche
und hauptamtliche Helferinnen die
unterstützen und beraten Integration
überhaupt möglich machen die dreijährige
maria hat wie alle Kinder hier einen
Platz in der Kita sie leidet unter der
Trennung von ihrem Vater der noch in der
Ukraine ist sagt ihre Mutter den Alltag
in Deutschland bewältigen sie vor allem
dank der
Gemeinde alles was wir brauchten haben
sie uns
gben die Ehrenamtlichen helfen so viel
bei Papieren Behörden Ärzten allem sie
helfen uns wie eine
Familie die Gemeinde hat zeitweise bis
zu 100 Menschen beherbergt und sie
machen weiter doch wie
lange wir haben am
Anfang haben wir ein unheimlich hohes
Spendenaufkommen gehabt und haben
seitdem auch sehr viel aus unseren
Rücklagen reingebracht in dieses Projekt
weil uns das wirklich ein
Herzensanliegen ist dass Menschen einen
guten Ort finden wo sie ankommen können
unterkommen können und merken aber jetzt
wir kommen auch finanziell langsam an
unsere Grenzen sie dringend staatliche
Unterstützung unklar ist ob sie kommt
klar ist berlin braucht Plätze und die
Gemeinde möchte den geflüchteten weiter
ein Zuhause bieten